[Music]  this is our best chance to find a  habitable planet  we breed and raise our own crew  three train them in isolation  to prepare them for life and space two  the voyage will take 86  i'm years of what  there's nothing to be scared of  you were the link between past and  future generations  and have been entrusted with the  survival of our species the normal kids  sensitive and smart i need to protect  them  there's a toxin in the water it's coming  from us  we're eating something toxic  it's the blue it's  to medication pleasure  i'm not drinking it what does it feel  like  to feel something  to prevent exactly this kind of thing  from happening  system restarting  we won't ever see the planet i want to  be honest with him  about everything he can't protect you  protect us from that  i'm scared there's nothing to be scared  [Music]  you